hey for those of you they haven't heard
it in a while I'm not picking on her at
all she's doing the right thing she's
thinking exactly the way we want you to
think after you officially you're in
Financial Peace University everything's
going the right way
but I get questions all the time from
people that are new to this whole stuff
that we're teaching we teach people not
to borrow money because that gives you
control of your largest wealth building
tool when you don't have payments you
have your largest wealth building tool
your income
you're not giving all your income to
someone else if you drive through a
major city you will see life insurance
buildings and banks in the skylines
Santa Claus did not build those he lives
in North Pole you built them by giving
the banks and the life insurance
companies your money and by the way they
kept it so that's what's going on here
it's a transfer of wealth you to them
stop it and so when we get you they in
that mindset then we have to look at
card payments car payments are a mantra
of the middle class lower class people
sometimes take out car payments but they
usually get completely screwed over at
the tote the note lot or the high
interest rate ripoff subprime or
something like that but middle class
people tend to buy new cars while
they're broke that go down in value like
a rock
that's where Chevy got that like a rock
it loses its value like crazy and you're
financing it and have a payment on it oh
and then a few years ago we got more
sophisticated and know we got Dumber we
got more and more stupid and we fell for
it again now 78% of the law of the cars
that leave a new car dealers lot our
least least let me tell you what Elise
is it's called it closed in lease you're
paying a payment monthly against the
value of the car you're renting the car
at the end of the closed-end lease
there's a residual value a lump sum that
is due if you want to keep the car and
so you pay five hundred forty-two
dollars a month on it for 30 months and
then you have the opportunity to pay
seventeen thousand four hundred dollars
to keep the car or whatever the number
is but that's how it works or you can
turn the stupid car
in at the end of that time and you have
effectively rented the car no you didn't
you rented the money that the car
represents when you rent money that's
called debt now you can call it a lease
if you want to call it a lease but
you're renting money which means I can
take that stream of payments that 30
payments of $549 I can take the 17,500
ollars or whatever the numbers are that
are at the end of the closed-end lease
and I can put them in my calculator and
I can put in the present value of them
of the sticker price of the car the MSRP
which is how this is calculated it's not
a bargain and then I can figure out your
cost of capital translation your
interest rate that you've paid in order
to lease the car on average with Ford
Motor Credit Lexus Motor Credit General
Motors credit Chrysler credit Toyota
Credit need I go to new do I need to
name all the credits okay I mean when
you put it in the calculator it comes
out 14.2% on average but by the way they
don't tell you you're paying a 14%
interest rate they don't have to because
you're not technically borrowing money
you're renting money and so it doesn't
fall under the federal Truth in Lending
Act and so you don't get one of those
little one-page confusing sheets that
shows you the effective APR that it does
if you actually borrow the money from
the bank or from one of those credits
but you've been renting money you've
been borrowing money now you know why 78
percent of the cars leave the lot now
with a car fleece
it's a fleece you got fleeced like a
sheep bad idea okay 14.2% sucks
get a clue okay this is a bad idea you
know why all those cars leave the lot
car least because it makes the car
dealer and the car company more money
and so they have trained you people like
a bunch of cattle
I heard we got a lot of animals in this
rant here okay but they've trained you
like a bunch of cattle to where you quit
asking how much rich people ask how much
broke people ask how much down
and how much a month what are my
payments and then they say stupid but
things like oh I can't afford that which
means if there are no bumps on the road
if my career never takes a left turn if
nobody gets sick in my family I might be
able to make the payments because this
month while everything is perfect I
think I can pay that payment
this is stupid y'all this is straight-up
stupid you know why people these cars
cuz it's almost nothing down it's more a
month and it's a higher interest rate
but it makes the car company money and
they're really good at selling it and
they look at you like you're an
unsophisticated dote if you don't lease
a car from them me I'm an
unsophisticated dog with tens of
millions of dollars because I quit
giving it to those idiots